this Black History Month we're bringing
you the story of three strangers
connected by the underground rail would
also pronounce railroad last December
the company ancestry of range for six
people from across the u.s. to meet at
an historical church in Brooklyn the
journey revealed family connections and
some surprises about their ancestors
which are documented in a 23 minute film
it's called
railroad ties the only thing the group
was told before they got to Plymouth
church was that they had heroic
ancestors from the slavery era Adriana
Diaz spoke with three of them only on
CBS this morning
dear Scott welcome to Plymouth church by
now you know that it was the Grand
Central Depot of the Underground
Railroad
if you look around you are among the
family members of Anna Maria weeds who
has a very personal connection to your
family when they first got to Plymouth
Church Seth Nichols Scott Pratt and
Cecilia Penn Diallo received letters
about their past that changed their
future they were strangers then I
wouldn't know what to do without the two
of them now but now back at Plymouth
Church just two months later they feel
like family you didn't think that I
would be ever sitting between these two
guys and calling them my brothers you
know but they are now and I dare anyone
to do anything or touch any one of them
because they got assisted I'll fight for
the nail what they discovered is that
they're not related through blood but
through a shared history there's an
amazing connection
yes back 170 years you know that we've
had the opportunity to learn about
together at the same time
Seth is a descendant of a prominent
Brooklyn abolitionist Lewis Tappan
I knew that my ancestor was an
abolitionist but I didn't have the real
connection of who he was helping one
person he helped with Cecilia's
great-great-great aunt Anna Maria Weems
to escape slavery she dressed as a boy
and was hidden in tappings attic so this
is where the runaway slaves would be she
passed through this dirt floor basement
of Plymouth Church on her way to freedom
and how does it feel to discover that
past for yourself personally and then
connection to the man sitting to your
right I mean it just makes it 100% real
and it comes full circle because now I
know my roots and it gives me kind of
chills as we sit here and I say that
because down deep in your soul you know
who you are and where you come from and
now I have flesh-and-blood brothers to
back me up and put that behind me it's
amazing it's amazing we love you as for
Scott he thought his Scottish roots
would lead him to a prominent forefather
all day long I have been asking satin
and everybody trying to find that
Scottish connection that Alexander
Hamilton connection but
his DNA revealed something else you are
the son of Christopher the son of Muriel
who was the daughter of Frank who was
the son of Mary the daughter of Sophia
Grey who escaped slavery with both of
her children through the assistance of
the Underground Railroad at the point of
the documentary where your history is
revealed I was like that's right Scott
is a descendant of runaway slaves his
ancestors passed as white
this isn't like my great great great
great great this is my great great
grandmother could have been dragged back
into slavery hmm
she was property at the end of the day
what they wanted to do and that was to
pass for white they did it successfully
so I'm so proud that I could be here
with you today but on the same token all
my heritage has been erased it's all
gone there's a lot of sadness around
that so you feel a loss for your
african-american history that you never
knew about oh yeah that's why Cecilia is
so significant to me she gives me that
connection to it she fills in that gap
that's been missing I'm Scott
but I'm a more enriched Scott than I was
before how does this change the way you
view Black History Month I think we all
inherit slavery in a different way some
of us inherit slavery from they were a
part of it some of us inherit slavery
that they still suffer discrimination
today some of us had heritage as we lost
parts of our family because they tried
to play themselves his wife we all have
to absorb it into a different way for me
Black History Month was history he was
sort of an intellectual exercise or
something appreciate you learn a lot
about suddenly I'm like no no actually
this is our history this is everyone's
history
the tap and family risked everything to
give others basic rights they knew that
respect for each other could make
America into a better place for their
descendants for you for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz that's such a great
statement we all inherit slavery in a
different way I also like when he said
you know when you talk about black
history it really is everyone's history
yes I love him making the distinction
about I hate the idea Black History
Month
should be every month it's not
intellectual when you're standing in
that church yes it should be every month
and by the way it's the shortest month
too I just think it should be really it
should be part of everyone it is it's
part of our culture absolutely agree
with that